ya sabemos lo que es una ecuación
química y aprendimos a balancear la
ahora aprenderemos sobre este geometría
una palabra que tal vez les hará pensar
que es un concepto muy difícil pero en
realidad solo es el estudio o cálculo de
las relaciones entre diferentes
moléculas de una reacción esta
definición es una traducción del sitio
wikipedia en inglés y dice este
geometría es el cálculo cuantitativo o
estimado de las relaciones entre los
reactivos y productos en una reacción
química balanceada en química se van a
encontrar mucho con esta palabra se
puede decir reactivos o lactantes los
lactantes se mencionan más en algunos
tipos de reacciones en donde se quiere
saber qué pasa pero decir reactivos o
restantes es lo mismo hagámosles tequio
metría y para seguir practicando
empecemos con una ecuación
desbalanceado
óxido de hierro
los átomos de hierro con tres átomos de
oxígeno más aluminio eso produce
óxido de aluminio
jr
recuerde cuando se hace este geometría
primero hay que asegurarse de balancear
la ecuación además creo que es bueno
porque así seguimos practicando tenemos
dos átomos aquí en este óxido de hierro
tres cuantos átomos de hierro tenemos
del lado derecho uno entonces hay que
multiplicar esto por dos ok
oxígeno tenemos tres de este lado y tres
oxígenos de este otro es también de
aluminio en el lado izquierdo sólo
tenemos un átomo y del lado derecho
tenemos dos átomos de aluminio entonces
pondré un dos aquí
así ya balanceamos esta ecuación ahora
hagamos algo de este tío metría este
kiómetro esencialmente es bueno no hay
un solo problema de este tío metría pero
lo más común es que por ejemplo si yo
les doy x gramos de esto cuántos gramos
de aluminio necesito para que esta
reacción suceda o si les doy 10 gramos
de esta molécula iceta gramos de esta
otra cual se acabará primero eso es la
este geometría no se preocupen haremos
los dos tipos de problemas digamos que
tenemos 85 gramos de óxido de hierro 3
y yo les pregunto cuántos gramos de
aluminio necesitamos cuántos gramos de
aluminio bueno si nos fijamos en la
ecuación podemos ver la relación molar
por cada molde óxido de hierro 3 que
usemos necesitamos 2 aluminio es verdad
entonces lo que hay que hacer es
averiguar cuántos moles de esta molécula
hay en 85 gramos y luego calcular el
doble que corresponde a los moles de
aluminio porque por cada molde óxido de
hierro 3 tenemos todos moles de aluminio
solo estamos analizando los coeficientes
estos números una molécula de óxido de
hierro 3 combinada con dos moléculas de
aluminio para hacer que ocurre esta
reacción
entonces calculemos primero cuántos
moles hay en 85 gramos
cuál es la masa atómica de esta molécula
lo escribiré aquí abajo
tenemos dos hierros y tres oxígenos
busquemos las masas atómicas en la tabla
periódica
el hierro está por aquí
55.84 bueno 55.800 45 lo podemos
redondear a 56 digamos que estamos
trabajando con el isótopo de hierro que
tiene una masa de 56 unidades de masa
atómica y para el oxígeno su masa
atómica es de 16
sabemos que la masa total de la molécula
será dos veces 56 + 3 veces 16 usemos la
calculadora
2 x 56
3 x 16 esto es igual a 160 entonces una
molécula de óxido de hierro 3 tiene una
masa de 160 unidades de masa atómica es
decir que un mal o 6.0 2 por 10 a la 23
moléculas de óxido de hierro es igual
pulmón es igual
a 160 gramos en nuestra reacción dijimos
que empezamos con 85 gramos de óxido de
hierro 3 cuántos moles son bueno
simplemente dividimos 85 entre 160
entre 160 esto es igual a punto 53 12 es
igual a punto 53 moles
así que todo lo que hicimos fue
averiguar cuántos moles de óxido de
hierro 3 hay en 85 gramos porque un mol
es igual a 160 gramos y son punto 53
moles por la ecuación ya balanceada
sabemos que por cada molde óxido de
hierro 3
tenemos dos moles de aluminio entonces
si tenemos punto 53 moles de la molécula
de óxido de hierro 3
vamos a necesitar el doble de aluminio
es decir 1.06 moles de aluminio
solo multiplique punto 53 por 2 porque
como les decía la relación molar es 1 a
2 si tengo una molécula de esto hay dos
moléculas de esto
si tenemos punto 53 moles y lo
multiplicamos por 2 obtenemos 1.06 moles
de aluminio muy bien ahora sólo tenemos
que saber cuántos gramos tiene un molde
aluminio y multiplicar eso por 1.06 así
que el aluminio vamos a buscarlo en la
tabla periódica
el aluminio tiene una masa de 26 puntos
98 lo podemos redondear a 27 unidades de
masa atómica entonces un aluminio es
igual a 27 unidades de masa atómica así
que un molde aluminio
un molde aluminio es igual a 27 gramos o
también 6.0 2 por 10 a la 23 átomos de
aluminio tienen una masa de 27 gramos
si tenemos 1.06 moles a cuántos gramos
equivale eso simplemente multiplicamos
1.06 moles de aluminio por 27 gramos
cuánto es eso
1.06 por 27 esto es igual a 28 puntos 62
así que necesitamos 28 puntos 62 gramos
de aluminio para que reaccionen los 85
gramos de óxido de hierro 3
si tuviéramos más de 28 puntos 62 gramos
de aluminio entonces habría un exceso de
esta molécula y quedaría aluminio aún
después de ocurrir a la reacción
hablaremos sobre eso más adelante en esa
situación tendremos más de 28 puntos 62
gramos de aluminio y esta molécula sería
el reactivo limitante porque tendríamos
más de lo necesario de esto y la
reacción se vería limitada por esto y si
tuviéramos menos de 28.62 gramos de
aluminio entonces el aluminio sería el
reactivo limitante pues no habría forma
de usar los 85 gramos todos los 85
gramos de óxido de hierro en la reacción
pero bueno no los quiero confundir con
esto por ahora en el siguiente vídeo
haremos todo un problema dedicado a
reactivos limitantes